boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are at the transformative technology
conference we our mind has been blown
over and over and over again we are now
with dr. Bashar but you're on thank you
for joining us thank you
really appreciate it likewise thank you
and Bashar is a neuroscientist at the
Medical University of South Carolina
it's correct and you were telling me
that you were working on the vagueness
or vagus nerve there's just a lot of
stuff that you're doing how will make
I'm excited to learn more about this
yeah Lots on Packo the transcranial
direct mate to write transcranial direct
current stimulation and CMS magnetic
stimulation it's all all of the above
yes so okay but even before we talk
about exactly what you've been up to
most recently let's talk about how you
even got excited about neuroscience like
who are you how did you get yeah so I'm
a trained neuroscientist from the
Medical University of South Carolina and
that's where I did my graduate training
I did it under the direction of Mark
George who is known for inventing TMS to
treat depression Wow
so kind of the pedigree in history of my
lab goes back to the 80s and in the 80s
was kind of this evolution of using
brain stimulation as a non
pharmacological intervention to treat
neuropsychiatric disorders so really
there's two kind of big findings in the
80s one was by Tony Parker who is from
the UK he's awesome dude he invented a
machine that can deliver magnetic
stimuli to the nervous system and my
mentor Marc at the time was training in
the UK saw one of these machines and
said hey we can put this on on the head
and stimulate the brain neurons in the
brain to treat depression and that's
what when it all started in the late 80s
it went on to the 90s where Matt MUSC
they ran all the early clinical trials
and developed TMS is now an fda-approved
treatment for major depressive disorder
and it took about ten or fifteen years
of development to get to the point where
a company neuron etics
ended up taking the technology running
with
getting an FDA indication for depression
so that is really a game-changer in
psychiatry it's really one of the only
non pharmacological interventions for
depression yeah
there is also one other really cool
finding in the 80s was we can we talk
about what part of the how would how
exactly is of course no TMS it's really
essentially a big stack of capacitors
electricity comes in from the wall is
stored in these capacitors and then
rapidly discharged at a specific
frequency through an electromagnetic
coil which is essentially a bunch of
copper windings right so an electricity
goes through these copper windings it
creates an induced magnetic field
magnetic fields a few centimeters and if
you put that on the brain on the skull
essentially and fire these magnetic
pulses at a specific pulse pattern you
induce electrical currents in the brain
those stimulate neurons and cause kind
of a long-term plasticity that helps
treat a variety of disorders for
depression we stimulate the left dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex EEG position
f3 which is like right here and if you
deliver about 10 Hertz
that's like executive functioning
correct cognitive functioning executive
control and also mood and so what we do
is we deliver TMS to that position five
days a week for four to six weeks and
people that have failed a series of
antidepressants several series of
antidepressants they're really
refractory they come in they see the doc
they get treated at the clinic and after
four to six weeks they can go back to
their jobs and it's and they're fully
better they remit so they come in with
really high depression rating scores the
hamilton rating depression rating score
in the 20s high 20s still used hamilton
the hamilton whose depression rating
score yeah so it's called the hamdi md
and that's used clinically it's a kind
of a clinical questionnaire that's
administered it's not subjective so I
would have a series of questions and
then the rater would rate your
depression symptoms interesting Oh
instead of himself diagnosing that's
interesting yeah so it's a we do these
weekly and we track the progress oh
that's how you know that TMS is working
yep oh because you're
you have like a psychiatrist that's
asking correct questions so the
psychiatrist is their weekly evaluating
usually so I'm like a Friday to get the
lay of the land and we contract usually
people respond to TMS in two to three
weeks and they're all the way better by
week six now we're making a lot of
advancements on kind of shortening the
total treatment length by doing multiple
sessions in a day so we can try to
shorten that treatment course from four
to six weeks to about two weeks with
these kind of rapid paradigms that we're
developing right now and and what are
you so now it's not tell us kind of like
the exact the exact process for somebody
they come in there Hamdi score is would
it be high or low and high it would be
high okay Hamdi scores high and then you
say okay we can do TMS right here on the
left dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex
correct and then we can do that once a
day for four to six weeks
correct and then we'll evaluate you
midway through and at the end or let me
evaluate it weekly and it's really daily
you know the physicians always
interacting with the patient and the
nursing staff and personnel we're seeing
these patients every day and then and
then what is what is what is going on
especially in that left do PFC area of
the brain like what where are you by
stimulating that area magnetically and
causing that area to fire what is why
why is that specifically causing them to
be less depressed like is it taking
attention away from another depressive
area or like how yeah how it's a good
question you know there's a lot of
different hypotheses on how a depression
works it's still kind of unknown but one
of the major ones is there is this under
activation in just resting activation
and the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex
so a lot of early studies in the 90s
were showing that there was decreased
metabolism so less active neurons in the
DL PFC that really elicited this kind of
target but there's also this idea that
that DL PFC is part of this
larger network with sub structures that
are deep in the brain like an interior
cingulate that are involved in mood and
salience right so it's kind of doing a
two-fold twofold when we do TMS in an
fMRI scanner so we can actually do TMS
in the scanner oh interesting is really
complicated and awesome
yeah we can look at what's happening in
the brain in response to a single
session of TMS yeah and we're creating
inks increased blood oxygenation level
dependent signal bold signal which means
that part of the brain in response to
the magnetic stimulation is becoming
more active for that period of time
slowly goes away the more you do it the
longer that effect stays eventually it
sticks
now does this potentially have something
to do with how when I feel like I don't
have something to like that my executive
functioning saying go and build this
aspect of whatever may brings meaning to
your life and if I don't have that
clicking I kind of tend to go to Netflix
or Facebook or whatever it might be and
I might not find as much meaning or
fulfillment in life by doing that
perhaps although maybe you're just
procrastinating from the task that you
really don't want to do yeah yeah so TMS
doesn't help with that yeah but people
that are depressed really wouldn't even
be able to watch Netflix some of the
patients we see are staying at home
they've generally quit their jobs they
really can't function some of them are
bedridden and stay in bed oh yeah that's
right so there's this idea or this term
called oneááá it was a movie on that I
believe it was a I don't think it was a
motor I don't think it was a motor
reason I think it was a depressive
reason what movie I I should remember
the name but that's like that yeah okay
so here's there are these physiological
problems that occur within us that cause
people to be better it yes yeah so
eventually that's called catatonia and
when you have catatonia you end up
actually being a little too sick to get
TMS you end up getting something called
ECT one of our friends and mentors
Harold it's a time for electroconvulsive
therapy I
think that might have been so there's an
old movie that kind of stigmatized ECT
called one one Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest yes nice yes and that actually did
I think a disservice to ECT because it's
really one of the most effective
treatments for depression that we have
when people come in with catatonia or
they're admitted into the unit ect
brings them right back to step one and
you only need about you know ten or
twelve treatments there's about three
treatments a week for a couple weeks and
they're way better than they started
Sunao sure where are you amongst
everything that you've been describing
are you analyzing things and making sure
that everything's going well out of the
whole so that's a great question usually
I'm the one that develops the new
paradigms so a couple of the kind of new
paradigms we thought is rather than just
focusing on the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex perhaps you can use
different cortical targets to stimulate
networks right so the most recent two
developments in TMS that I did in my lab
was one targeting the pre supplementary
motor area which is right here that's
connected to deep motor control networks
and we did that to treat essential
tremor we also use that site to kind of
detune the obsessional thoughts in OCD
so we did that in 2013 and 14 and now
that's actually gone to FDA approval now
people can get TMS for OCD based on that
early findings we do TMS paired with an
exposure therapy and it gets people who
are refractory in their OCD treatment to
pretty much remit so they get all the
way better in OCD it's amazing so that's
kind of some of the stuff we do in the
lab we have an active brain stimulation
clinic that treats folks from the
community that are usually depressed
bipolar anxious and then we developed
the new paradigms but that's only kind
of one third of what we do we also do
something called vagus nerve stimulation
which was developed in the 80s by jigs
abara who's a friend and mentor in the
early 80s base ism
beautiful nerve that goes the vagus
nerves awesome it's really this large
central bundle of nerves
it runs from your brain all the way down
and targets every smooth muscle organ in
your body stomach heart lungs spleen
kidneys intestines bladder all of it Wow
so your eyes allow you to see what's in
front of you and what's in this room and
I could look out and there's someone
swimming in the pool but your your
internal organs need to communicate with
your brain - and the vagus nerve is how
they communicate with the brain kind of
like how your eyes communicate with your
brain with the optic nerve yeah that's
what the vagus nerve is for and if you
look at all of the hydrogen highway of
communication yeah it's really a
superhighway and it's this bundle that
can target all of these nerves it's a
majority of your daily life functions
that you even don't even know that or
there that are on these are the
autonomic it's an autonomic nervous
system nerve it's really associated with
the parasympathetic nervous system or
the slowing of bodily functions so
there's really two autonomic control
systems the sympathetic which is really
your fight-or-flight and gets you up and
stressed and ready to evolutionarily
escape from a stressor with the
parasympathetic which allows you to slow
right go to sleep relax your heart rate
digest and so those are cholinergic so
acetylcholine as a neurotransmitter
associated with this pathway the vagus
nerves dumped a seal choline onto these
organs and the causes of relaxation and
slowing that process starts at the brain
acetylcholine is the neurotransmitter
that the correct never dumps into the
Sun to the organ 44 the parasympathetic
nervous system functioning correct but
that is initiated in the brain so before
it dumps any type of neurotransmitter
yeah there is a complex system that
initiated kind of in these deeper brain
structures that then send the signal out
to the vagus nerve so there's like
there's this from the brain we go down
there's all the cerebral spinal nerve
system and then there's also the vague
vagus nerve system Siskin oh yes the
vagus is in your thorax so it's in your
in the cavity in your body's cavity it
doesn't initiate in the spine that's
wandering he's so Vegas yeah
is that as Latin for wandering for
wandering so it haha it used to do is
called the wandering nerve and I'll show
you an my talk later today that it was
there is this Italian neuroanatomist
that dissected the body in the 1500s
it's this beautiful image of all the
nerves in the body spine and you can see
the vagus nerve is literally the the
most complicated part of the entire
thing and so that's where it got its
name as the wandering nerve because it
just travels throughout your body huh
and what's interesting is there's not
only efferent effects or from the brain
to the body but you can actually go from
the body to the brain right so it's
bi-directional communication and we can
take advantage of that by stimulating it
to access deep parts of the brain okay
now teach us about how to stimulate the
vagus nerve and what it does so in the
early
well actually it's really late 1980s
there was a neurophysiologist Jaques
Barra who had a epileptic dog model so
k9 dog that had epilepsy he implanted
the electrodes onto the nerve directly
of the vagus nerve and when he turned on
electrical stimulation externally
internal internally okay so you do the
dissection okay and you access it really
kind of in the cervical part of your
neck you can't do external stimulation
of vagus nerve that's what you can and
that's what we've been developing okay
sorry I jumped the gun keep yeah yeah
but all the early studies were
implantable in fact when you turn on
electrical stimulation onto the nerve
you stop the epileptic wait for stops
epilepsy so that's where vns started and
from then on Jake is nerve stimulation
yeah the VNS actually Jake interesting
fact that not a lot of people know is
that he called it a Neurosci Burnette ik
prosthesis but the the medical community
community didn't really understand that
and they changed the name to vagus nerve
stimulator
so initially was NCP which then became
VN s I like NCP better but VN s is cool
and it's tucked so that ended up
becoming the company that Jake founded
called cyber onyx and over a hundred and
fifty thousand people across the world
have been implanted with a V NS
stimulator to treat their refractory
epilepsy whoa thirty to forty percent of
people implanted have reductions of more
than seventy five percent of their daily
seizures that did not respond to meds
it's amazing so just a little
electricity here actually ends up
stopping your seizures yeah and then
from then on there is actually a really
astute and this is like a cool history
lesson an astute hotel clerk that
noticed that these patients that had
epilepsy that were coming to stay for
follow-up visits their moods were
getting better and reported it to one of
the docs at school there they they then
explored V&S to treat depression and
they treats depression whoa so it became
this epilepsy treatment depression
treatment recently it's been FDA
approved for chronic morbid obesity so
if you plant stimulators at the level on
the v8 on the vagus nerve right above
the stomach yeah it decreases your
appetite and reduces obesity symptoms so
a will lose body fat that sounds a lot
better than the gastric bypass surgery
well in fact when people get their
stomach stapled for those types of
procedures sometimes in rare cases
there's a mistake and they actually
staple over the vagus nerve and if you
damage the vagus nerve all the
downstream communication for the vagus
becomes interrupted so it's actually
pretty risky so that I mean these are
all the developments but you can't
really implant everybody to try out a
bunch of stuff it's expensive it cost
about $50,000 you have to go into the o
R and do it any surgeon trained in head
and neck dissection can do it but it's
not really common for individuals that
are exploring you for other things so
what my groups been doing I've been
doing a lot of research on this in the
last five years is developing
non-invasive vagus nerve stimulation
so rather than implanting electrodes you
can stimulate a branch
the vagus nerve that innervates your ear
mmm that's called the auricular branch
of the vagus nerve and you can use
electricity to stimulate that nerve and
mimic the effects of implantable which
now has opened up this entire field of
vns to everybody it reduces heart rate
it increases heart rate variability it
treats depression mm-hmm it doesn't work
super well on epilepsy but that's
because it's still early and the dose
isn't optimized but not where it is that
my lecture would go externally so the
electrode goes in your ear so you can
stimulate the auricular branch of the
vagus nerve either in the left or right
here and this small little off branch of
the main bundle can be targeted in your
ear right in there's a couple different
targets one is the anterior wall of the
external ear canal so like your tragus
but on the back side of your little
triggers or you can target the Simba
Concha which is this kind of top part on
the inside circle of your ear or you can
target it on the mastoid whoa and you
can just you can is that um is that a
electrical stimulation electrical
stimulation so we a long time ago they
tried to do magnetic stimulation there
but it's uncomfortable to deliver
magnetic pulses there because there's a
lot of muscles so what we thought was
perhaps we can do electricity to mimic
it we started these studies in 2013 and
we explored the entire parameter space
so low frequency high frequency big
pulse width long or short pulse width
long stimulation short stimulation
different electrodes different different
targets and over the years we've
optimized this technology and now it's
rolling out into several clinical trials
across the United States so this is all
at MU at MUSC okay and how long has it
been that you've been doing that there
six years six years there yeah and then
you have a lab there Korean what's the
lab called
so it's the brain stimulation lab brain
stimulation lab kureta and how many
people are in the lab right now the lab
is pretty big so we have around 20 staff
20 staff we have the division director
mark George who's still around we have
three other faculty there who do a
variety of things for
a nurse stimulation to treat addictions
PTSD working with veterans there's a
really interesting individual of dr.
Sheng Valley who does
TMS for smoking cessation that works
really well to help people quit smoking
which is a really big problem in the
United States
well this list is crazy okay so helping
were smoking helping with addiction
helping with PTSD helping with with
potential stumps
gasps hunger expressing saw the but I
think what the most cool part of the
entire thing is besides all of these by
the way we're doing Parkinson's with
vagus nerve stimulation but the most
interesting that the project is that I'm
doing with dr. Joe Jenkins who and
there's a pediatric neonatologist he's
using non-invasive vns cared with bottle
suck training in preterm neonates to
accelerate the learning of how to feed
and put down formula to be discharged
from the hospital faster when they're
born with a hypoxic ischemic event and
what's the hypoxemic event so prevents
them from being discharged so before the
when the babies are born either preterm
or at term but with essentially a brain
injury where they lose oxygen to the
brain they don't have the ability to
feed on a bottle so what they do is they
stay in the nursery with their family
for up to six weeks and they're trained
how to use a bottle suck on a nipple and
put down food if they don't put down
food they get discharged with a gastric
gastric tube GI tube Wow where the mom
then has to feed the baby through a port
in the study so what we thought was we
can take advantage of this vagus nerve
which also enhances kind of a global
meta plasticity we pair vagus nerve
stimulation with training and
rehabilitation on how to feed with
occupational therapists and the babies
rather than waiting 6 weeks and then
getting a GI tube over half of them are
discharged without a g-tube and they
could discharge way faster so between 10
and 20 days rather than six weeks
yeah yeah so that's really the most
promising MUSC yeah and so that just got
published recently as a brief report now
we're doing a larger clinical trial yeah
and how many children are born with an
ability to to [ __ ] on the nipple you
know I'm not too familiar with the
percentages but it's pretty common and
these a lot of the babies that are born
preterm don't have this ability so even
if you don't have the hypoxic ischemic
event a lot of babies are candidates for
g-tubes because they just can't learn
how to feed now you don't hear about a
lot of these cases you really hear about
the healthy ones oh I had a healthy baby
and it's doing great but there's a lot
of babies in the in the unit that have
this difficulty feeding and get sent
home with a surgery energy - Wow
holy cow the char I am so impressed
there's so much so much different
stimulation that can occur electrically
magnetically to solve so many different
problems that exist in in in humans that
that I think can help create a healthier
happier civilization oh yeah and you're
you're investigating into all of these
range we test all of them and what's
really fascinating is that these
technologies end up trickling down to
people like me Neil so we take these
treatments that help people and treat
disorders then we investigate how they
can help us in our day to day life one
of the prime examples is what I was
telling you earlier is using tDCS
this low electrical current stimulation
of about two milliamp that runs off a
small 9-volt battery he's pretty cheap
and inexpensive we use that to help
people feel calm and relaxed and
accelerate their meditative practice so
that was something that we used to
research for pain and cognitive
enhancement has now trickled down into a
paradigm called a meditation that came
out of MUSC as well and we use that we
are actually demoing it here at the
conference there is 40 people in Vermont
that are doing the first-ever brain
stimulation retreat where they meditate
at a monastic center for five days using
brain stimulation to augment their
meditation practice yeah it's really
cool stuff so that method is called a
meditate
I'm thinking about that for a while
because whenever I go to the 10-day
meditation retreats they just came back
from one uh-huh I always loved the idea
of thinking how to augment its 2500
years ago when this is you know
conceived this isn't really you know we
didn't have the like TD see they see us
and we didn't have access to so many
like other psychedelics that we could
you know so there's so many different
ways to kind of add variables to the
meditation mixture to just see what
happens yeah yeah so what you know we
what we know is safe and we know
actually works in the Sikh brain is now
coming to individuals in the healthy
brain to optimize human performance and
help help us connect and interact with
each other and hopefully make a better
world one day if we can all connect with
each other and be kind to one another
through these really transformative
technologies like a meditation we can
really change the world and that's what
we've been developing at MUSC it's
really exciting so that's the stuff that
gets me out of bed every day as is doing
the whole gamut of brain stimulation and
hopefully one of these things will be
able to be used in the general public to
improve day to day life I love it you
are amazing you're amazing you know just
so I'm so grateful to have been able to
interview you I think there's a lot of
cool collaboration explorations we can
do with an organization called brain
mind we'd like to potentially loop you
into that as well as you know neuro
scape over here at Hannigan's Ellie's
lab over here great there's a lot of
cool stuff to explore so I'm again super
grateful for you think of course hey no
problem catching us about everything
you're up to yeah thanks for having me
it's really cool your story's incredible
and what you're working on is amazing so
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below also go
and build the future go manifest your
dreams into the world everyone thanks
for tuning in much love that was so fun
man you are you are you are a rock star